all this month children all across
america are going back to school which
means that all across america teenagers
are signing up for s.a.t prep classes
kids take the sats because they're an
effective way to measure academic
ability except what if they're not what
if that's not what they were designed to
do at all let me explain in a segment
called how did we get here
there are a few things that every
american high school student can count
on experiencing algebra acne and filling
in tiny bubbles
but standardized testing wasn't always a
part of american education in fact just
like your favorite thrift store jacket
standardized testing started out in the
military
in 1917 a group of psychologists created
an entrance exam for the u.s army it was
given to new recruits and the purpose
was to separate those who were mentally
superior from those who were mentally
inferior kind of like what you do when
you look at tinder tender profiles
i know i'm not looking i'm not looking
at dinner
you tell me probably
a few years later a psychologist named
carl brigham seen here right after
becoming haunted
published a study analyzing the results
of those tests he announced that black
people had scored the lowest he claimed
american education was declining and he
blamed that on the intermixing of black
and white people he said the decline of
american intelligence will be more rapid
than the decline of the intelligence of
european national groups owing to the
presence here of the negro what i'm
saying is he sounds like a really fun
guy
now
i guess it is possible that black
recruits actually did worse on that
man's made-up test but here's the thing
when a bunch of white people design a
test around the things they know then
they are by definition designing a test
that white people will do better on
because every test is biased toward the
people who create it if sir mix-a-lot
creates a test about which types of
butts are best you know the answer is
going to be big
so
our haunted friend carl here created a
biased test but when he said that his
test proved that black people were
inferior white people were ready to
listen and when immigrants started
showing up in the u.s in greater numbers
in the early 1900s the people in charge
of immigration got a great idea they
decided to use these new intelligence
tests to choose who could enter the us
and who couldn't sort of like a racist
bouncer they were used to prove that
non-white people were at the lower end
of the racial ethnic and cultural
spectrum and they weren't just written
in a biased way they were also written
in english which many immigrants didn't
speak fluently
can you imagine trying to take a test in
english when you don't speak english
that's like me trying to watch a
telenovela i don't understand what's
happening i just understand that the
stakes are
very high
as these intelligence tests became more
widespread white supremacists started
using them for more than just the
military or immigration they started
using them as a scientific sounding way
to justify segregation and even as a way
to justify forced sterilization of
people of color and people who were
intellectually disabled now that is a
very heavy piece of information so let's
just take a moment and reset with a
picture of two animals hugging
there we go
all right you fell for it now
what does all of this have to do with
the sats well at the height of the jim
crow era white schools were looking for
new and exciting ways to keep black
students out and in the 1920s they said
oh you know who we should call haunted
curl
america's college board asked carl to
create something called the scholastic
aptitude test or the s.a.t that they
could use to eliminate undesirable
applicants and carl said stand back i've
been training for this my whole life
harvard was the first school to require
all students to take the s.a.t so i
don't know how to break this to you but
some racist stuff happened at harvard
the test was such a hit other colleges
started using it and by the mid 1900s
standardized testing was widespread
creating an even larger disparity in
access to education these tests became a
barrier to knowledge and generational
wealth for many american families of
color because that was precisely what it
was designed to do for instance sat
designers used old test questions to
design questions for next year's exam
old questions were deemed good questions
if black black and latinx students
scored lower than their white peers so
if white students did well on a question
it would be moved to the new test
centering the test around their
knowledge base basically the old test
was right in the new test like this
see there you go
and i'm not just talking about how they
made the test in olden times on the
october 1998 sat white students scored
higher than black students on every
single one of the 138 questions every
single one
they could have saved some time and just
had one question are you white yes you
get a 1600.
now many people have asked how can we
make a test that is more accessible to
students of different racial and ethnic
backgrounds but
as we send our kids back to school this
month maybe the question is why are we
using standardized tests at all because
the goal of these tests was never
education it was always exclusion and
that fact is haunting which i guess
explains carl's face this has been how
did we get here
[Applause]
[Music]
you